donald trump has now floated the idea of
invalidating and redoing the november
presidential election
at some point in the future trump did
some kind of event commemorating women's
right to vote it was really bad from the
get-go and here is donald trump saying
we might have to redo the election
because of all of the voting that will
be done by mail
we have to have honest voting that's
what this
is all about here it's honest voting you
can't take
millions of ballots send them
haphazardly all over the country or
all over a state and expect to
come out properly and if you look at the
last ten elections where they did this
universal
and by the way absentee is great it's
been working for a long time like in
florida
absentee you request and it comes in and
then you send it back
absentee is great but universal is going
to be a disaster
the likes of which our country has never
seen
it'll end up being a rigged election or
they will never come out with an outcome
they'll have to do it again and nobody
wants that and i don't want that
so trump's first salvo was that it might
take days to know the results
now people weren't really worried about
that it would be fine for it to take a
few days as long as we get the right
results so trump had to scale it up he
had to go hyperbolic and then trump went
to saying
you know it could take days weeks or
even months to know the results of the
november election
that just wasn't believable so more
recently trump's been going full
fake panic by saying it could take years
to know the results and now he's added
this cherry on top
the craziest which is we might have to
throw out the election results all
together
and redo the entire election now what's
funny is when he says that
he never says what would be different
when we redo it like is is the
implication
we would have to redo the election but
without any voting by mail like what
what how would the next how would we
doing it
fix the problem unless we do the
election in a different way
doesn't really matter this is all crazy
now donald trump also had announced on
monday night
this is so crazy on the way back from
his rally in wisconsin
trump announced on monday that yesterday
he would be making a big announcement
about pardoning someone and he said
it's not going to be snowed in it's not
going to be i don't remember whoever
else
and he made this announcement yesterday
during the same event commemorating
women's right to vote
donald trump announced that he would be
pardoning
susan b anthony who died in 1906
the announcement which trump had
promoted as a major announcement
it was met with literal laughter in the
room you have to see this video you have
to listen to this
you're going to hear loud laughter when
trump says i'm going to pardon susan b
anthony
people think it's a joke and then they
realize
oh my god trump is serious and they
start to clap
sort of like politely out of pity i i've
never seen anything like this
incredible document that i'm signing and
i wanted to just
add something because this was brought
up a week ago
and i was so surprised that it was never
done before
because later today i will be signing a
full and complete pardon
for susan b anthony she was never
pardoned did you know that she was never
pardoned
what took so long the women behind trump
literally think it's a joke that trump
is telling that it's not real
they thought this was going to resonate
somehow the white house did
why else would they do this and then a
moment
that is indistinguishable from parody
donald trump is asked if he supports the
protesters in belarus and trump i guess
heard
protesters and terrorists and it just
gets really weird it's like a weird
freudian slip combined with
trump going off the rails and bashing
the protesters
in portland oregon when asked about
belarus take a look at this
protesters do i support protesters and
terrorists
oh i thought he said protesters and
terrorists have a message
for moscow regarding potential military
yeah you have to understand me i like
seeing democracy
democracy is a very important word it
doesn't seem like it's
too much democracy there in belarus
but we are speaking to lots of people
and we'll be speaking at the appropriate
time to russia
and we'll be speaking to other people
that are involved but it's certainly a
very big
march and it seems to be a very peaceful
march other than the
other unlike some of the so-called
peaceful protests that we have where
they burn down stores
okay peaceful protest those are not
peaceful those are anarchists
going over to portland and other places
these are anarchists agitators these are
very bad people
just a complete and total inability to
discuss
policy in anything approaching
substantive a substantive way and then
lastly trump is asked about michelle
obama's dnc speech from monday which
even fox news said was pretty good
and he says she was dead wrong we have
way more coronavirus deaths than she
said we have
trump's trump's fact check if you can
imagine maybe
because the speech was recorded a few
days earlier trump's fact check is
her speech was bad because under my
administration we've actually had
way more coronavirus deaths than
michelle obama claims
yeah no she was over her head and
frankly she should have made the speech
live which she didn't do she taped it
and it was not only taped it was taped a
long time ago because she had the wrong
deaths
she didn't even mention the vice
presidential candidate
in the speech and you know she gets
these spawning reviews if you gave a
real review it wouldn't be so phony
owning the libs by saying no no no
michelle was wrong
more people have died of coronavirus now
she recorded it a couple of days ago and
then
absolute last thing on this trump again
talks about how the obama administration
got
bad reviews on swine flu notice if
you're watching this video
the woman over trump's left shoulder she
looks physically ill during this take a
look
well they got very bad reviews if you
look at the gallup poll
gallopol did a review of them now you
have to understand that was a far lesser
uh vicious disease it was not the same
in the same ballpark but yeah i know
it's also a much lesser disease
but they got very bad reviews gallup
gave very bad reviews and by the way
gallup at that same time
gave us very very good reviews for the
job
we've done so if you take a look at the
gallup poll
from a couple of months ago we got very
good reviews and they got very bad
reviews they were
they were i mean the reviews they got
for the handling of
swine flu or h1n1 which biden calls n1
h1 and i don't even correct him on that
i don't even correct him i said nah
that's a mistake you can make
but that's what he calls it he's got the
he's got it a little mixed up but that's
all right
take a look at the gallup poll and there
were others too
they got horrible marks and that disease
is a
much lesser problem and of course we've
already fact checked this
during swine flu the obama biden
administration had 66 percent approval
in a polarized political environment
like the one that we have
66 percent approval getting 66 of the
country
to agree on on anything is an
accomplishment in and of itself so trump
also wrong on the facts
and making people look physically ill
from these rants
and then trump flew out to arizona
and it got even worse and i'm going to
talk about that next
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video